this is how we lose because we fail to
understand what the left understands
which is that if you accept the left's
basic premises those premises are
eventually going to be taken to their
logical conclusions if you accept the
premise in this case that men and women
are basically the same you can start
that out in the 70s you can start that
out with feminism you are going to end
up here you can try to slow it down a
little bit you can try in vain to push
pause on the unfolding of history based
on certain premises but you're never
going to stop it you're certainly never
going to stop it at transgenderism is
fine but non-binary is crazy